what is an emotional event
an emotional event is something that
happens
it's something that happens that changes
the temperature the emotional
temperature of the scene
so it could be a turning point
or it could but it it doesn't have to be
a single moment it can be the what
happens in the whole in the whole scene
so so the whole scene could be an
argument
or well let me mention
Mike Nichols who I quote a lot in my
book directing actors 25th anniversary
edition I quote Mike Nichols a lot in
the chapter on emotional event
because he really really got it he was a
teacher himself and in addition to being
a brilliant director and
[Music]
um
and he said at one time and I'm going to
preface this by saying that I make some
adjustments to this uh victim of Mike
Nichols I I take the Liberty uh he said
every scene is either a fight a
negotiation or a seduction
and
that's a useful way for directors to
kind of get introduced to the idea of
emotional event is it's something that
big and you know they're that different
from each other you know a fight a
negotiation seduction they're different
from each other
and uh and that's a helpful way for
people to think about I actually think
that it can be you know refined you know
and ARG I was using the example before
an argument between best friends
oh who have never argued before is
different from an argument between
people who have had many arguments in in
the past right those are two different
kinds of arguments but um but it it it's
something that it's something that
happens between the the two people the
two characters in the scene that uh that
changes their relationship
so
um
and I in this I'm very proud of this
chapter five in
in this book very proud of the chapter
five because I I finally really really
addressed this question of emotional
event I in the first book uh the
original directing actors which came out
in 1996
I mentioned emotional event and I
mentioned how important it was but I
didn't really describe it and over the
years that I was teaching after that and
people would have they were asked to
read that book before they came to any
of my workshops and the directors would
always say you know I love the book but
I'm still this one thing I'm confused
about and it's emotional event so I so I
kept trying to uh be clearer and clearer
about it and it's a very slippery topic
you know it's one of those things you
know I'd I'd I was in class I would
finally be reduced to saying you know
if you keep watching me men talk watch
scenes and talk about emotional event
you'll eventually be able to do it
yourself and I thought well that's a
cop-out you know I have to be able to uh
to really describe it for them more
clearly and then I TR then I did another
book in 2003 called the film director's
intuition and I I made a stronger
attempt to describe what emotional event
is in that book but I still wasn't
satisfied and people still had the you
know kept asking about it so in this
book the 25th anniversary edition of
directing actors I I really went all out
I spent a lot a lot of time uh trying to
explain it from a lot of different
points of view because it's it's it's
slippery and and uh so I came at it from
different points of view like you could
think of it um does it is the it at the
end of the scene is the relationship
closer than it was at the beginning or
is it more alienated than it was at the
beginning that's a simple way to look at
emotional event and uh some other simple
ways are
uh one character hurts the other
person's feelings
that's an emotional event or one
character uh
asks uh asks for forgiveness and
receives it that's another emotional
event or one person
um uh
try uh tries to pick a fight and the
other person engages you know they pick
a fight with each other
so that's a that you know so there are
different ways of of looking at it but
um and it takes a lot of practice to you
know to think about that what is the
event of the scene
and and that it's something underneath
the plot event
and so Mike Mike Nichols said there's
three sort of wants in every scene it's
one to argue no no no that it's either
one of the that is seen as either a
fight sure or negotiation or seduction
right so it's it's one of three
yeah I mean it's a it's a I think he was
you know it's it's a very broad thing to
say I mean one thing that uh that it
makes me realize is that
um you can play fast and loose that that
a lot of you would think any love scene
is a seduction right that would seem
automatic but but actually most love
scenes are negotiations
so that's an interesting way to do it
um I would think that the scenes in
Fight Club where they're having the
fights you would think that those are
fights right but they're really
seductions
so you can
I don't know you're looking for what's
underneath it what if a scene does not
have an emotional event you're going to
end up taking it out in the editing room
if it doesn't have an emotional event
it stops this it stops the story so that
even uh scenes that look like a
connector scene or an exposition scene
still need to have an emotional event
there's no such thing as a scene that uh
that that's an exposition scene
so I was very lucky with uh with this
25th anniversary edition of directing
actors I was I was very lucky to get uh
permission to use a seed from The Matrix
for to do my script analysis uh example
and it's a it's a very short scene it's
like a page and a half and I think most
people would look at it and think it's a
connector scene they're you know they're
they're in a car they've
just derived back to the Matrix and it's
Neo first visit back to the Matrix
I think they're on the way to see the
oracle and um
so it's a connector scene between this
you know very amazing uh
trip from the Nebuchadnezzar
back to the Matrix and then and then
this amazing scene at the at the
oracle's uh uh office
and um but but I it's because it's an
excellently written script and I just
found so much in it and so so I was
really I really felt good about being
able to show how something that most
people might think of as a connector
scene had lots and lots of event in it
even if the most simplest Exposition
scene Shakespeare is full of them a
messenger comes up and tell gives
information to the to the king and then
goes off that you could say that the
emotional event is that the messenger uh
you know the Chiefs achieves their
message that it it raises their stature
in the eyes of the king or it cements
their low stature
when they're when they're dismissed you
you can find emotional event in any uh
so-called Exposition scene and you must
you must
what are the questions that a director
should ask to uncover the emotional
event
great question okay I I go into that a
lot uh and one way that you know and any
question that occurs to you like why are
they here why why is this you can always
start with why is this scene in the in
the script uh why why why do the
characters do what they do why do they
say what they do
um I like to always start with
mysterious lines mysterious lines very
helpful place to start when I'm doing
script analysis so well first I look at
just my my my first impressions
what I I honor my first impressions
where I say uh and even if it's oh this
is a scene that uh looks like a torture
scene you know one person is is beating
down the other person
so that would be something I don't like
I don't care for torture scenes so I
would say well I gotta find something
else then and say oh so I so I honor
that I for I have that first impression
or I have the first impression that that
um that's a love scene that these people
are are falling in love
it's one of those little steps along the
way to Falling in Love
so that's so I honor my first
impressions but then I start looking for
mysterious lines and I make myself find
at least three in every scene and and
first I look at mysterious lines the
ones that bother me the ones that it's
my tenants that I my first impression my
first tendency is to say I don't like
this line it shouldn't be here it should
be Rewritten uh I I don't like it and
then make myself come up with three
different ways of understanding it make
myself
and by the time I've done that I
I'm fine with the line I don't I don't I
no longer want it to be taken out which
is very very good thing to use for if
you're directing television if you're
directing television you don't get to
change lines or take them out if you
don't like them not without permission
certainly and and uh you're very
unlikely to get it
so it's very very useful to uh to be
able to find a way to justify any line
that at first you don't like
of course I have a theater background so
that's how I learned that because you
didn't if you're doing a Tennessee
Williams play you didn't say well I
don't like this line can we change it no
you don't you don't get to change it so
so um so you have to find a way to
justify it you know so finding a way to
justify the line
so I start with the lines I don't like
and then I start with the lines that I
love sometimes there are lines that I
love and then I make myself still look
for subtext to them
instead of saying this line is so good I
just have to say it and it's you know
going to be wonderful I still make
myself look for uh you know what are
three different realities that could be
behind it
now
I should probably give you an example
huh
yeah I would just just real quick what
would make you not like a line
well I was thinking about this this
morning
and I was thinking about because
um you know like
I
I
decided to think of something from
Shakespeare because
you know we don't have to worry about
copyright if I use some lines from
Shakespeare right so when I was thinking
about to be or not to be speech which
goes to be or not to be that is the
question
whether it is nobler in the mind to
suffer the slings and arrows of
Outrageous Fortune
or to take arms against a sea of
troubles and by opposing end them
well this is a line that I both love and
hate
the the line about take arms against a
sea of troubles and by opposing end them
I mean I love this line it it seems to
so perfectly
um
say something about the State of Mind of
a of suicide ideation
you know that that the only there's
nothing I have nothing I could do I
can't
and Powerless to change anything any and
um and even
my efforts to change you know I'm
powerless powerless powerless but if I
look at it in a very word by word kind
of way take arms against a sea of
troubles
that's a mixed metaphor
right
why did he do that this is Shakespeare
he doesn't have to mix his metaphors he
he you know he can do anything so why
did he do that you don't like the idea
of shooting bow and arrow into the into
the waves that's the image that comes up
when I think about it you know the Sea
of troubles it's like the waves crashing
over the shore you take a bow and arrow
and and well actually as soon as I say
that I say yes everything that we do in
life is as futile as shooting bows and
arrows into the into the waves
so we'll automatically
I like the line better but then I I say
to myself well make myself come up with
two more
and
um and the another one that of course
comes to me is that you know the mixing
of the metaphors is a product of his
disordered mind
that uh I mean sometimes I think I think
about how that a lot actually and
sometimes especially in the last week
because I went to see that movie The
Northman which is based on the same uh
Legend the same story as the Shakespeare
used to based uh
to base the story of Hamlet and
um anyway
sometimes I think that Hamlet
Shakespeare's Hamlet
was
uh had early onset schizophrenia you
know brought on by trauma
and uh and that his mind really is and
that this speech which it's so beautiful
that you think it all makes sense but it
really doesn't and it's not meant you
know that it it doesn't make sense
because his mind is going from image to
image
anyway that that's I I just did too I'm
gonna stop because sometimes I talk too
long about Hamlet so
I'll I'll just I'll just stop there to
come up with at least at least two three
if you can different ways to understand
uh a line that that bothers you